dwayne johnson
and he reads his you know his
endorsement and by the way if you've
seen this if you're watching this if
you've seen it
how many guys have already seen when he
makes his endorsement about who he's
going to vote for
okay here's what he said let me just
read it to you
my conversation with joe biden and
kamala harris as a political independent
and centrist for many years i voted both
for democrats in the past as well as
republican
in this critical election i believe joe
biden and kamala harris
are the best to lead our country and as
my first
ever public presidential endorsement i
proudly
endorse them for presidential office of
our united states
progress takes courage humanity empathy
strength grit and kindness
and respect being kind and respectful to
one another will always matter
and then he did an interview with both
them for about five or six minutes
and he talked a lot about trust you know
he was mainly talking about trust you
know it's very important to trust
how can we trust that you're gonna
deliver and keep your award how can we
trust they're gonna deliver and keep
your award
and uh the audience reacted i think
there was a couple hundred thousand
comments
some were happy some unfollowed some
were disappointed somewhere
he got beat up a little bit what are
your thoughts when you saw that well
okay
here's my thought number one watching
the video
is a lot different than reading it when
i watched that video i thought i was
watching a hostage
you know like how a hostage has to get
in front of a camera when your captors
are forcing you to say something rich
limbaugh you know had some interesting
comments today he was very very forceful
talking that this is all about china
all right that according to rush that
this is pleasing his masters in china
because of the funding for the films and
how well his films do
in china so when i watched that tape i
thought i'm watching a guy that didn't
want to be doing this
okay he didn't vote in the 2016 election
he didn't even vote
and now it's so important for him to
even endorse one of the
candidates so i found the whole thing
odd it opens up a lot of questions
uh a lot of the funding does come from
china his movies do
well in china you know it would be who
uh
the biden administration to have china
support and
does the rock move the needle with
people probably although he did get beat
up
and crushed a little bit more than i
thought i thought everybody would be
just praising him on social media
he got hammered a little bit so i found
the whole thing awkward and staged
and really not sincere to be honest with
you not 100 sincere
well the the initial hostage video was
the first video he did about a month ago
where are you where are you yeah yeah
where are you yeah
i mean he really went into rocky he did
he did and pat
does play a good rock when rock is
unavailable uh matt zappala i think was
uh
that's a good point if you're listening
shout out to
rock's uh look alike look alike i mean
these days he's as big as the rock
i don't think this was a good idea by
the rock
i don't see a lot of upside for this for
the rock
he must have thought i'm gonna piss some
people off yeah i already have 100
million instagram followers we did the
debate
of who would make a better presidential
candidate the rock
or lebron overwhelmingly people said the
rock movie star
dominant force lebron a little too left
in many people's ideas
i don't know why the rock came out and
decided to do this i don't see a lot of
upside he's a beloved
figure on the left and the right i don't
know
i mean he only he can answer that
clearly
clearly you know when they say if it
walks like a duck it talks like a duck
the guy has made multiple videos
disparaging trump at this point
why can't we just take it on the surface
where he just doesn't care for trump
can we is it just that easy as that
that's how you process it
oh by the way multiple videos like that
matt sapolo responded say yeah i
am and he said the little uh cousin of
the rock that is lol so he got what you
said here we love you
but but uh uh mike what do you think
about it michael before i'll give my
thoughts here in a second i
i agree i believe it or not i agree with
adam um
i i don't i don't i don't see an upside
there i just really don't i you know
what i
part of me was wondering i was like wait
a second you know he hasn't worked in a
while it seems i felt like he was
putting a movie out every two months
yeah and then with covet or whatever i
mean is it is it part of holding on to
relevance kind of you know doing
something to shake the trees a little
bit or something like that i mean i
don't know i didn't i didn't see an
upside either
can i respond to that sure all right i'd
like that something that we can even
talk about right now
who's paying the rox bills i know we
brought up china hollywood ladies and
gentlemen
hollywood is hollywood more liberal or
conservative
you guys there's a there's a really easy
explanation for this that dude is like
in level 10 jumanji right now
i mean he doesn't know what he doesn't
even know i don't know why we didn't
think about that guys too
at the moment like he doesn't he doesn't
know what's going on he's you think he's
more rockstar brains and donkey brains
than biden right now is what you're
saying i think it's i think it's rubbing
off you know i would love to see the
rock have more of his wrestling persona
i miss that yeah he was the greatest
entertainer in the world as a wrestler
and now
you know he's the rock he's a great
actor is he not the biggest movie star
on the planet right now well i mean
who's bigger than the rock i'm not
saying he's not being bigger
[Music]
okay i loved his personal other than
samuel jackson pat
let's let's let's kind of unpack this on
all levels let's look at it from all
angles okay
uh on one end he becomes the two-time
back-to-back making the most money in
hollywood as an actor
124 million dollars income and the next
year i think he makes relatively around
the same number as well
a big part of because he started doing
movies
that have to do with china so that's
number one his movie started getting
picked up in china he did that one movie
where he's the hero he's climbing in
this big building
tall buildings he's coming down
skyscraper that movie did
incredible and he realized if i do
movies
that are not good for china i get paid
20 million bucks maybe 25 million
dollars
but if i do with china i get paid 40 50
million dollars so
you got to know from that standpoint
that business is business is business
okay
so even if biden raises the taxes to
39.6
let's say he does so you make 25 million
if you do movies that aren't state
now you do a movie that's going to be
also sold in china but you're going to
make 50 million
39.6 of 50 million is still more money
than 20 on 25 million if that makes any
sense so he's not sitting there saying
i still would like to see something take
place with china so i understand the
argument about
him wanting to protect china i think
biden china really wants biden to get
elected you have to understand this
china iran north korea wants biden to
get elected it is that simple
okay china iran north korea wants biden
to get elected that's the one thing to
be thinking about
now whether you like china iran or north
korea that's up to you
if you're somebody that wants china to
get stronger iran to get stronger in
north korea to get stronger then biden's
your candidate it's that simple
i'll give you the other side um
when has there ever been a time where
the face of hollywood hasn't voted left
never when has ever been a time but
clintus was never been the face john
wayne he's been a great actor
that's that's a long time ago right so
you're talking about years ago you're
talking about during
our lifetime you've not had somebody
that's the face of hollywood
that's voted on the left so let's flip
it say
for example say for example let's
actually be advisors of the rock
rock calls me for advice and rock says
hey pat i'm being pressured in hollywood
man to vote
dude what do i do seriously they're
telling me because i gotta protect
kamala
and i gotta come out and you know my
manager and all the people that is on my
camp they're all about biden they can't
stand trump
bro what do i do i got to win this
hollywood because these movies and all
that what do i do
what would i tell them i'd say you know
what honestly when i look at you you
have the american flag up all the time
you know you're all about america you
love america everything about you is
about america
you look like a guy that if you ran
today for office you'd be a center right
guy
you don't look like a left guy i said
you're better off not saying anything
if he asked for advice from me not to
say anything
but say if you said to him come out
publicly and say you vote for trump
why because who ran wwe who was the guy
that ran it
what is the difference between mcmahon
and trump what is the difference between
mclean and trump so the guy that changed
your life
is twins like trump they have everything
is in common
between those two daughters running the
business i mean you go down the aisle
mcmahon and trump are twins so if you
support mcmahon that change your life
this is the same guy that you're voting
for so imagine if
rock does come out and he says i support
president trump what would have happened
to
rock 24 hours later i actually want you
to think about this so as a
business advisor would you have told
them
if he's openly calling you you're the
person you trust the most
would you tell him behind closed doors
go ahead and come out and say you will
you uh want to uh
endorse trump would you have because if
he did his career in hollywood
is over i wouldn't say anything he
couldn't he could that's the point
trump right i mean the other option is
not doing anything and then the third
option is
endorsing biden and it all is because of
china i think your analogy with the you
know when you look at the increased tax
and whatnot
he still has to pump these movies out in
china and that's the bottom line
but he could have done nothing like tom
cruise does right no one knows which way
tom cruise votes
still does pretty well pretty big movie
star so
someone was telling him to do this and
he listened there are very few people in
hollywood that are untouchable
when it comes to things like this so
there are very few people that are going
to go against
the norm because their careers are on
the line you know what i mean and so
it's
like i remember when i remember when ice
t came out
in favor of gun rights and it was a huge
deal
and everybody was talking about it
everybody's like i can't believe ice t
like i never would have thought ice t
this you know would say this and that
he's for you know gun rights or whatever
and then ice t's response was
what are you gonna do to me i'm iced tea
i've done
everything like i have everything what
are you gonna do to me
give me my guns but but but that is
the the part about that is he's in the i
don't give a [ __ ]
mode he can do that okay clint eastwood
is in the i really don't give a [ __ ]
like dude what are you going to say to
me
but vince vaughn comes out and he
supports ron paul
what happens to him when's the last time
you saw him one of the
funniest actors of our era this guy did
a movie called
psycho i believe i don't know what movie
it was what was america he did something
psycho he crushed it in that and then
you go from that to the wedding crashes
and then you go
i mean the guy's a ridiculous actor
right where is vince vaughn
where where is mel gibson mel gibson one
of the best actors of our era now i know
some of the comments he made
when you see the awards ceremony that
they had two years ago guess who was
sitting at the same table
go look at the word ceremony right at
the front you know who's sitting at that
table
vince vaughn mel gibson sitting right
next to each other
because they relate in a way they've
both been ousted mel gibson's one of the
best actors in the last 40 years
in that world you're walking on
eggshells
if you say anything so the point you
made a very good point
the difference is the rock still gives a
[ __ ] and if he still gives a [ __ ] he
cannot change his position
guys let's not forget for the longest
time trump trump was a democrat
let's not forget for longest time for
the longest time he was a democrat he
gave money to everybody
everybody because he still gave you know
like listen i gotta be careful i gotta i
need these guys to change certain laws i
need these guys to
do certain things he give money to
everybody i just don't i think if if
trump if a
rock would have came out and he would
have said listen you know trump's
changed my life i'm going to endorse him
i think it would have been very ugly for
the rock and his career would have been
absolutely over oh yeah he couldn't have
done that so i don't think he could have
done that
do you think he was forced to do it or
do you think he chose to do it so
there's the other story that's coming
out saying they have a uh
something on him like you know maybe
there's a story of him with another
woman or there's a story on him with
a weinstein and all this others and
quite frankly if
that does happen man what a life to live
to be held hostage for something that
somebody has a video
a text an email a racist thing that he
did 20 years ago that's going to come
out today and they're going to say
imagine if you're held hostage for that
the rest of your life every single thing
they say
you have to do i just don't see rock
being that where it's something like
that i simply think he chose career and
he was the right move to make today to
say i'm going to go for biden and
kamala actually don't think it's bigger
than that yeah i and there's do you
think there's any economic impact it's
like when michael jordan says hey
republicans buy shoes too
he stayed out of everything is there is
there any economic impact do you think
for
him taking decide like that are people
going to choose not to go to the movies
that he's in
well the way you got to look at it is
how many followers he lost his instagram
account didn't lose followers he was at
198 million followers uh
three days later he still had 198
million followers 199 million followers
so if you go look at his impact
i don't know he's more like nike to me
nike announced kaepernick
they went up i don't see this thing
taking a big hit
[Music]
you